look at this oh black could bring the
queen right down into the corner maybe
that's just deadly bring
okay
this one is strong as well this is good
yeah and uh probably yes
going to find it in the next move
because i think yes there's also a rook
check once the white queen moves out the
way black's rook is going to come down
with a check that's going to be
checkmate white's king too open
well he had to do this i mean uh he
could have held the draw but he had to
he had to campbell so i mean uh his king
was actually too weak there in the end
but why not go down and blaze the glory
rather than fade away and uh that's what
he's done he's gone down in the blaze of
glory or oh wow
you know only an option esopenko
relieved he knows he's got this in the
back no matter where the white king goes
there will be a check and there will be
a checkmate on the next three or four
moves it's over
wow
it's over the quarterfinals are over
andreas panko makes it through to the
semi-finals what a performance it's been
in the tournament by eric hanson